So hello, everyone, darling listeners.
It's Emma Thompson here, calling you from Blighty, the shores of Great Britain.
My microphone is propped up on, well, actually, one of the boxes has got my quite posh cards in that I recently invested in,
which had my name in tiny little, really sort of delicate letters.
And I felt it was sort of quite, I just thought it was classy.
Anyway, I may be wrong, of course. I often am. So the books are Truth and Repair by a woman called Judith L. Herman, author of Trauma and Recovery. You may be getting a sense here. Then there's Getting Over Your Parents, which is a very important book for anyone who is human. And then there's On Being Nice, which, of course, is a very important thing, but don't take it too far. That's what I always say. Oh, there was one other thing.
Welcome to Smartless.
I'm an actor and I have to be on camera today.
大家好，亲爱的听众朋友们。我是艾玛·汤普森，现在从大不列颠的海岸——英国，向你们问好。我的麦克风架在……其实，其中一个盒子里装的是我最近投资买的那些相当考究的名片，上面印着我名字的字体非常小，非常精致。我觉得这挺有格调的。当然，我也可能错了，我经常出错。所以，这些书是朱迪思·L·赫尔曼写的《真相与修复》，她也是《创伤与复原》的作者。你们可能已经感觉到什么了。还有一本是《克服原生家庭》，这对任何人类来说都是一本非常重要的书。接着是《关于友善》，当然，这是一件非常重要的事情，但别做得太过火。我总是这么说。哦，还有一件事。欢迎来到《Smartless》。我是一名演员，今天还得拍戏。
Oh.
Here, have you been working on your faces in the mirror all morning?
Yes.
Yeah?
Let's see. Surprise.
Surprise.
Let's see surprise.
Wow, great.
哦。在这儿，你整个上午都在镜子前练习表情吗？是的。是吗？让我们看看。惊讶。惊讶。让我们看看惊讶。哇，太棒了。
God, that's so good.
Now, one with the mouth closed?
One with the mouth closed?
Still rolling?
So, Sean, you shoot today.
That's how J.B. directs.
Yeah, I do right after this, actually.
J.B., is that how you direct actors?
天哪，太好了。现在，来一个闭嘴的？闭嘴的？还在录吗？所以，肖恩，你今天拍。JB就是这么导戏的。是的，其实就在这之后。JB，你就是这样指导演员的吗？
Still rolling, still rolling?
And one with the mouth close?
Okay.
Good, good, good.
By the way, Ben.
Don't look right at the camera.
Still rolling?
还在录，还在录？来一个闭嘴的？好的，好，好。顺便说一下，本。别直视镜头。别直视镜头。还在录吗？
By the way, I just got that note.
I'm not even kidding.
Sean, can you close your mouth in the scene?
No.
I swear to God.
Was it a dialogue scene?
Did they just want you to stop talking?
顺便说一下，我刚收到那个指示。我没开玩笑。肖恩，你能在戏里闭上嘴吗？不。我发誓。不。那是对话戏吗？他们只是想让你别说话吗？
No, it was just like my character.
It was like, I can't believe what you're saying.
Like, I was just like, are you serious?
Like, kind of, I was serious.
I was like, and she's like, can you do it with your mouth closed?
Could you?
Could you do it with your mouth closed?
I tried.
不，就像是我的角色。就像是，我不敢相信你在说什么。就像，我当时就是，你是认真的吗？就像，某种程度上，我是认真的。我说，然后她说，你能闭着嘴做吗？你能吗？你能闭着嘴做吗？我试了。
But you're like, I have dialogue.
They're like, yeah, we know.
Just mouth blows.
Yeah, I'm just propping my mouth to talk.
And you're going to go on background.
That's going to be your cue.
And just try thinking your lines on this take.
我试了。但你就像，我有台词。他们就像，是的，我们知道。只是闭着嘴。是的，我只是在用嘴说话。你要进入背景。那是你的提示。这一条试着在心里默念台词。
Here we go, everybody.
Wait, you know, I was doing this scene once years ago,
and Eli was there.
We were in France.
And I had to this long shot.
I'm walking down the thing.
And I get to the end.
And Eli goes, bro, your legs are really wide apart.
开始了，各位。等等，你知道吗，多年前我拍过一场戏，伊莱也在。我们在法国。我得拍一个长镜头。我走过那个东西。然后我走到尽头。伊莱说，兄弟，你的腿张得太开了。
Okay, your gate's really wide.
And I go, oh, okay.
And I had to do it like five more times.
The whole time I'm just thinking about it.
I was walking.
Close your legs.
Which is the worst.
That's the way you walk.
好吧，你的步子迈得太大了。我说，哦，好吧。我不得不又拍了五次。整个过程我都在想这个。我在走。合上你的腿。这是最糟糕的。那就是你走路的方式。
I could do your walk in two seconds.
I know.
I know I walk.
Oh yeah,
you're a little bow-legged.
Yeah.
Like you just got off a heart.
Well, hang on.
我两秒钟就能模仿你的走法。我知道。我知道我走路的样子。哦，是的，你有点罗圈腿。是的。就像你刚从马背上下来。好吧，等等。
This is not an excuse to just pile on.
I'm very vulnerable this morning.
I think I'm actually bow-legged.
I don't think, Will,
you're bow-legged.
You just happen to swing your legs around one another when you walk forward.
It's because I have long legs.
You do have long legs.
这不是你们群起而攻之的借口。我今天早上非常脆弱。我想我确实是罗圈腿。我不认为，威尔，你是罗圈腿。你只是走路向前时腿会绕来绕去。那是因为我腿长。你确实腿长。
I was thinking about you watching all the hockey this weekend with you filling up
that goal crease.
Yeah.
You know, you need a tall guy in there, right?
Get that shoulder up into the high corners.
Well, back in the day when I played,
it was much more about getting on the ground
stacking the pads.
我刚才在想你这个周末看冰球比赛，你填满了那个球门区。是的。你知道，你需要一个高个子在那儿，对吧？把肩膀伸到高角去。嗯，我打球的时候，更多的是趴在地上堆叠护具。
Oh, sure.
You know, stack in the pads.
Instead of a butterfly.
So, Will, with you being a Toronto fan,
are you keeping it with Canada
and rooting for Montreal?
I sure am.
Yeah.
哦，当然。你知道，堆叠护具。而不是蝴蝶式。所以，威尔，作为多伦多球迷，你还在支持加拿大，为蒙特利尔加油吗？我当然是。是的。
I'm all the way.
Yeah.
And Sean, who's your pick to win this cup?
Between the two, between Canada and...
Over there at the...
Well, it looks like it's going to be Vegas.
Which is a little air.
It's a layer afterwards, but it's pretty exciting.
我全力支持。是的。肖恩，你觉得谁会赢得这次奖杯？在两者之间，在加拿大和……在那边的……嗯，看起来会是维加斯。这有点……但还是很令人兴奋。
Will you stick, a couple of years ago, or three years ago,
Will had me record my picks.
Do you remember that?
Oh, yeah, for the Stanley Cup.
Yeah.
And so every week I would record the picks and why they would win.
Sean, I'm going to give you three guesses
what the name of the team in Las Vegas is called.
威尔，几年前，或者三年前，威尔让我录下我的预测。你记得吗？哦，是的，为了斯坦利杯。是的。所以每周我都会录下预测以及他们为什么会赢。肖恩，我给你三次机会猜猜拉斯维加斯那支球队的名字叫什么。
The hockey team.
Okay, let me ask you this.
Does it have something to do with the city itself?
It does not.
Yeah, it really doesn't.
Yeah, they're not called the chips or the cards.
Yeah, no.
What about...
冰球队。好吧，让我问你这个。它和城市本身有什么关系吗？没有。是的，真的没有。是的，他们不叫筹码队或纸牌队。是的，不。那……
It's Elizabethan.
I'll give you a hint.
It's Elizabethan, or it's like...
Well, I mean...
Kings, the Kings.
Are they close.
That's close.
I mean, it could be any of those...
它是伊丽莎白时代的。我给你个提示。它是伊丽莎白时代的，或者它是……嗯，我是说……国王，国王队。他们很接近。那很接近。我是说，可能是其中任何一个……
The Golden Knights.
All right.
I tell you who's golden.
Oh, here he comes.
Will's got a lunchekeye.
You guys like a segue?
金骑士队。金骑士队。金骑士队。好吧。我告诉你谁是金子。哦，他来了。威尔有个午餐……你们喜欢过渡吗？
Yeah.
Well, I mean, she's golden in that,
I mean, you know, she's obviously won two Golden Globe Awards
and been nominated for like 11 or something.
Wow. Yeah, yeah.
And won two Academy Awards of the five that she's been nominated for.
Oh, no. Wait a second. Five nominations. That's...
是的。是的。嗯，我是说，她是金子般的，我是说，你知道，她显然赢得了两座金球奖，还被提名了11次左右。哇。是的，是的。在她被提名的五次中赢得了两座奥斯卡奖。哦，不。等等。五次提名。那是……
And in fact, she's the sole artist thus far to be,
to have received an Academy Award for both acting and screenwriting.
Acting for Howard's End.
Screenwriting for Sense and Sensibility.
Emma Thompson.
Well, Emma Thomas.
Guys, it's just Emma Thompson.
I can't even get into her credits.
事实上，她是迄今为止唯一一位同时获得奥斯卡表演奖和编剧奖的艺术家。凭借《霍华德庄园》获得表演奖。凭借《理智与情感》获得编剧奖。艾玛·汤普森。嗯，艾玛·托马斯。伙计们，只是艾玛·汤普森。我甚至无法列举她的成就。
It's Emma Thompson.
Emma Thompson, no word.
Hello.
Incredible.
I'm nice to see you.
I literally didn't understand a word of any of that.
是艾玛·汤普森。艾玛·汤普森，没别的。你好。不可思议。你好。你好。很高兴见到你。我刚才说的那些话我一个字都没听懂。
I love the people.
Oh, my God.
Three guys talking about hockey, it's fascinating.
I love your refugees on the floor in the background.
Yeah.
Oh, can you see them?
Yeah, sure.
That's my daughter and her boyfriend.
我喜欢这些人。哦，天哪。三个男人谈论冰球，太迷人了。我喜欢你在背景地板上的难民。是的。哦，你能看到他们吗？是的，当然。那是我女儿和她的男朋友。
They can't hear you, which is just tragic.
is that all they can hear is me and they're used to me, so why don't you give them a chair to sit on?
They're going.
Why don't you can?
Now, where are you?
Are you at their house or your house?
No, I'm in my office, actually.
他们听不到你说话，这太悲剧了。他们只能听到我说话，而且他们习惯了我，所以你为什么不给他们一把椅子坐呢？他们要走了。你为什么不能？他们要走了。现在，你在哪儿？你在他们家还是你家？不，其实我在我的办公室。
I was looking behind Sean, he's got a very posh kind of array.
Oh, you should see it when it's a tax the awards back there.
There's awards.
There's like loads of statues and portraits and photos and books.
It's a mess.
And Jason's got like some sky, which is good.
And Will is in deep darkness, which given the fact that he's giving us kind of vampire voice,
it also works, you know.
我刚才在看肖恩身后，他有一个非常考究的陈列。哦，你应该看看当它被奖项堆满的时候。那里有奖项。有大量的雕像、肖像、照片和书籍。那是一团糟。杰森有一些天空，这很好。而威尔处于深沉的黑暗中，考虑到他正在用那种吸血鬼般的声音说话，这也行得通，你知道。
It's all making more and more sense.
Yeah.
Now, we were making fun of Sean the other day because he had one of his awards behind him.
And I moved it.
For some weird reason on their Zoom frame, usually includes any awards that one may have won.
you don't have any awards behind you
and you've won tons.
Where are they all?
这一切越来越有道理了。是的。现在，我们前几天还在取笑肖恩，因为他身后放着他的一个奖项。我把它移开了。出于某种奇怪的原因，他们的Zoom画面通常包括一个人可能赢得的任何奖项。你身后没有任何奖项，而你赢得了无数奖项。它们都在哪儿？
Yeah, where are they?
The Oscars are in the Levertree
because that just keeps them in their place.
The Globes and the Bafters and all that
are on a very high shelf somewhere
where I can't see them.
I don't know.
I think that's very British.
是的，它们在哪儿？奥斯卡奖在书房里，因为那样能让它们各就各位。金球奖、英国电影学院奖和所有那些东西都在某个我看不见的高架子上。我不知道。我觉得这很英国。
We have a friend that has an award
and she keeps it in the bathroom as well
and puts the toilet roll
on one of the extended limbs.
It's a holder.
Yeah.
That's taking it even further than me.
You know what?
我们有个朋友有一个奖项，她也把它放在浴室里，把卫生纸卷放在其中一个伸出的肢体上。它是个支架。是的。那比我做得更过分。你知道吗？
I think that maybe you ought to go the other way,
which is have a table right in your foyer
as you walk into your place with a spotlight.
Yeah.
And just lean into it.
You know what I mean?
So they know what they're dealing with.
That's it.
我觉得也许你应该反其道而行之，在你的门厅里放一张桌子，当你走进你的地方时，上面有一个聚光灯。是的。然后就顺其自然。你明白我的意思吗？这样他们就知道他们在和谁打交道了。就是这样。
Or you just put them in the doorway
like just so that when people come in,
they just trip up over them.
I'm so sorry, this is my Oscars.
Sorry.
I'll just move them.
Right this way.
Yeah.
或者你只是把它们放在门口，这样当人们进来时，他们就会被绊倒。真抱歉，这是我的奥斯卡。抱歉。我这就把它们移开。这边请。是的。
Just on the floor.
Do come through. Do come through.
Would you like to freshen up?
Yeah.
And then have copies of them in the toilet so they can't get away ever.
And then another, you know, just have them everywhere.
Yeah.
就在地板上。请进。请进。你想梳洗一下吗？是的。是的。然后把它们的复制品放在厕所里，这样它们就永远跑不掉了。然后另一个，你知道，到处都是。是的。
So people just go, I need to leave.
Why not lean into it?
I think that that's a good idea.
Where is your office?
Are you in England or New York or Los Angeles?
I'm so in England.
But it doesn't feel like it today.
Actually, everyone is experienced.
所以人们只会说，我得走了。为什么不顺其自然呢？我觉得这是个好主意。你的办公室在哪儿？你在英国、纽约还是洛杉矶？我当然在英国。但今天感觉不像。其实，每个人都经历了一场创伤，一场伦敦式的创伤。所以我现在在伦敦，北伦敦，我一生都住在这里，我从六岁起就住在这条街上，所以那是60，那是16。那很酷。是的，奇怪，相当奇怪。总之，突然间，我们遭遇了热浪，
a trauma, a London trauma.
So I'm in London, North London,
where I've lived all my life,
I've lived on the streets since I was six years old,
so that's 60, that's 16.
That's cool.
Yeah, weird, quite weird.
Anyway, suddenly, we got a heat wave,
这显然与气候变化无关。对。不，全是希望。我们为什么要暗示那个呢？但伦敦现在是35度。而且，你知道，东西就在你面前死去。宠物、家用电器、花，一切都在枯萎。
which obviously has nothing to do with climate change.
Right.
No, it's all the hopes.
Why would we even suggest that?
But it's 35 degrees in London.
And, you know, things are just dying in front of you.
pets, household, appliances,
flour, everything is just wilting.
就像，你知道，德古拉走进了镇子。而且也没有多少空调，对吧？我们只是不能，我们不知道。我们这里没有空调，别开玩笑了。或者冰。我们一年有三天热天。或者冰。但它们有36度。
It's like, you know, Dracula's walked into the town.
And there's not a lot of air conditioning either, right?
We just can't, we don't know.
We don't have air conditioning here, don't be ridiculous.
Or ice.
We have three hot days a year.
But they're 36 degrees.
或者冰。对吧？虽然那正在到来。艾玛，为什么会这样？那正在到来。为什么欧洲整体上似乎都达成了一种共识。在这方面谈谈欧洲。
Or ice.
Right?
Although that's coming.
Emma, why is that?
That's coming.
Why is it that Europe, on the whole,
somehow sort of all made a consensus decision.
Take on Europe on this.
碳酸饮料加冰块味道不会更好。我是说，很明显它们会更好。这在客观上是事实，对吧？但你还得要求加冰……我听起来像个丑陋的美国人。我道歉。不，你只是对冰着迷。美国人一直对冰着迷。
That carbonated drinks don't taste better with ice cubes.
I mean, it seems pretty clear that they do.
That's just objectively true, right?
But yet you have to ask for ice with a...
I sound like an ugly American here.
I apologize.
No, you're just obsessed with ice.
Americans have always been obsessed with ice.
你对它着迷。我很抱歉，但你确实是。当我第一次到达美国时，冰就被送来了。你简直被放进了一个该死的冰浴里。我们对此感到非常兴奋。进入冰里。进入冰里。你会喜欢的。
You're obsessed with it.
I'm sorry, but you are.
When I first arrived in America,
and ice was just brought.
You were practically put in a fucking ice bath when you were right.
We were so excited about it.
Get in the ice. Get in the ice.
You're going to love it.
你会喜欢的。所有东西都加了冰。你知道，鸡肉帕尔马干酪也加了冰。这是怎么回事？这太疯狂了。你不是对它着迷。我们没有那种痴迷，因为我们可能没有那么多钱，
Everything came with ice.
You know, chicken parmesan came with ice.
What's going on here?
This is mad.
You're not obsessed with it.
And we don't have that obsession
because we don't have probably as much money
而且我们的冰箱没那么大。它们不产冰。我们都买了声称产冰的冰箱，结果一周内就坏了。那你怎么避暑？你只是脸朝下躺在人行道上喘气。保持静止。希望有只狗过来在你身上撒尿，
and our refrigerators are not as big.
and they don't produce ice.
We all get fridges that say they produce ice
and within a week they've broken down.
So what do you do to beat the heat?
You just lie face down on the pavement panting.
Stay still.
Hoping that some dog will come and whittle on you
给你降温。我是说，我们没有方法。但关键是，你只是，你只是接受它。我们不需要一直处于完美的舒适区。这就是生活的全部意义。有些事情会发生，
and cool you down.
I mean, we don't have methods.
But here's the thing, you just kind of,
you just take it.
We don't need to always be in our perfect comfort zones
at all times.
That's the whole point of life.
There are things that happen.
在日子里你会感到热，你会这样做，有些日子会冷，但确实在这个国家，我是加拿大人，顺便说一下，艾玛，所以我站在你这边。我知道你是加拿大人，亲爱的。但我认为你们习惯了极端温度，而我们生活在温带地区。
in their days where you're hot,
and you do,
and there are days that are cold,
but it is true that in this country,
I'm Canadian, by the way, Emma, so I'm with you.
I know you're Canadian, well, darling.
But I think you guys are used to extreme temperatures
and we live in a temperate zone.
是的。我们真的不习惯。现在，因为气候变化，看看我的脸。我是说，我和我衬衫上的条纹颜色一样。这太悲剧了。但是，你知道，就像，我们只是不习惯。而且这相当，真的很奇怪。
Yes.
And we're really not used to it.
And now, because of climate change,
look at my face.
I mean, I'm the same color as one of the stripes in my shirt.
It's tragic.
But, you know, it's like, we're just not used to it.
And it's quite, it's really weird.
是的。其实。太热了。去年夏天怎么样？去年夏天那里也超级热，对吧？欧洲经历了一场巨大的热浪。超级热。我当时在坐地铁。
Yeah.
Actually.
It's so hot.
How was it last summer?
Last summer it was super hot there too, right?
Europe had a huge heat.
Super hot.
And I was traveling on the tube.
你在那儿吗？我去年夏天在那儿。他在演他的戏。哦，天哪。太热了。而且，就像大家说的，没有空调。我们住的地方有空调。但有，我们在一个像温室一样没有空气的地方排练。
Were you there?
I was there last summer.
He was doing his play.
Oh, man.
It was so hot.
And, and, like, to everybody's point, there's no air conditioning.
We were staying in a place that had an air conditioning.
But there was, and we were rehearsing in a place that was like a greenhouse with no air.
那剧院呢，肖恩？剧院有空调吗？剧院里没有空调。不。什么？我们的剧院里没有空调。得了吧。因为我们以前从不需要它，而且我们还没有适应气候变化。
And what about the theater, Sean?
Did the theater have air conditioning?
No air conditioning in the theater.
No.
What?
No, there's no air conditioning in our theaters.
Come on.
Because we've never needed it before, and we haven't adapted yet to climate change.
我想，艾玛，你在谈论坐地铁。你坐地铁时体验如何？在伦敦，你是否经常被人们拦住并围住问问题？不，不。不，一点也不。没人会在地铁上注意。他们都在看手机。但我的猜测是，当他们认出你时，那是一件
I want to, Emma, you're talking about taking the tube.
What's your experience like when you take the tube?
Are you, in London, are you approached constantly and mobbed by people asking you questions?
No, no.
No, not at all.
Nobody takes any notice on the tube.
They're all looking at their phones.
But my guess is that when they do recognize you, it's something.
非常迷人且尊重的事情，他们会说他们喜欢哪部电影之类的，她是一位受人尊敬的演员，而不是像你看到的那种名人，就像长颈鹿从动物园逃出来了，你得在手机上拍张照片，是的，是的，你是对的。
very charming and respectful
and they say which movie that they love
and stuff like she's a respected actor
as opposed to like a celebrity
like you see a celebrity out it's like
it's like a giraffe has escaped the zoo
and you've got to get a picture of it on your phone
yeah yeah you're right
我很幸运，我想，因为在欧洲也是一样，人们与我有一种关系，我不知道你们是什么情况，但你知道，你一定有这种经历，杰森，人们与你可能扮演的某个特定角色，或者也许几个角色有一种关系，我们做了很多很多不同的事情。我想如果，例如，你是一个动作英雄，
I'm very lucky I think because it's the same in Europe
people have a relationship with
I don't know what it's like for you guys but you know
you must have this Jason that people have a relationship
with a particular role that you might have played,
or maybe a couple,
and we've done lots and lots of different things.
I think if, for instance, you're sort of an action hero,
我可以想象对于像，我不知道，施瓦辛格，或者史泰龙，或者布鲁斯·威利斯，你知道，那么每次都会有非常具体的反应。但对我来说，你知道，我可以不被注意到，不一定是不被注意到，但当然，这从来不是个问题，其实。你最不喜欢哪种粉丝互动？比如当你和家人在一起时，或者，我是说，因为就像有一些，
I can imagine that for somebody like, I don't know,
Schwarzenegger, or Stallone, or Bruce Willis,
you know, then there's a very specific response every single time.
But for me, you know, I can pass,
not necessarily unnoticed, but certainly,
It's never been an issue, actually.
What's your least favorite kind of interaction with a fan?
Like when you're with your family or, I mean, because it's like there's some,
如果它引起了骚动，我总是会感到尴尬。换句话说，引起了其他可能不知道我是谁或没注意到我的人的注意。你知道，就像，当它只是那种温和、安静且擦肩而过时，这很棒，对吧？是的，我是说，这很可爱，人们会从你身边经过，然后继续走。是的，是的，是的，是的。
I always get embarrassed if it ever causes, like, a scene.
In other words, grabs the attention of others that might not otherwise know who I am or notice.
You know, like, it's great when it's just sort of.
mellow and quiet and
passing, right?
Yes, I mean, it's lovely and people will just
pass you and still keep walking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
他们说，喜欢你的作品，再见！是的。这很可爱。但当你和女儿买香肠时，你真的不想让他们走过来问，能合个影吗？自拍很有趣，不是吗？
They go, love your work, bye!
Yeah.
It's lovely.
But when you're sort of buying
sausages with your daughter,
you don't really want them to come up and go,
can I have a selfie?
Selfies are interesting, aren't they?
你们对此感觉如何？对。你觉得它们有侵入性吗？一点点，你怎么看？嗯，不，但我注意到的是，在过去，通常是签名，如果你没有纸
How do you guys feel about those?
Right.
How do you feel about the,
do you feel that they're intrusive?
at all, what do you think?
Well, no, but what I have noticed is that
in the old days, it used to be
autographs, and if you didn't have a piece
或笔，那么就只是，嘿，很高兴见到你，喜欢你的作品，那是一个夜晚。但现在每个人都有手机，所以即使你不想要签名，对吧，斜杠照片，你还是会觉得有义务，好吧，我最好拍一张，你知道。所以人们有点排队。
of paper or a pen, then it was
just, hey, nice to meet you
and like your work, and it was a night.
But now everybody's got a phone, so even
if you don't want an autograph, right,
slash picture, you still sort of feel
obligated, well, I better take this, you know.
And so people kind of line up a little bit.
总之，我不是想抱怨。你曾经拒绝过吗？不，从来没有。我和别人在一起过。我不，我是说，从来没有可能，我可能会，我肯定我有，但我没有。我和孩子们在一起时有时会，如果我和孩子们在一起，或者和小孩子在一起，如果是一个成年人问，我会说不。我从来没有拒绝过孩子。我说过。
Anyway, I don't mean
to sound like I'm complaining. Do you ever say no?
No, never.
And I've been with people.
I don't, I mean, never is probably, I might, I'm sure I have, but I don't.
I do when I'm with the kids sometimes, when I'm with, when I'm with, if I'm with the kids or with the little kids, and if it's an adult asking, I'll say no thing.
I've never said no to a kid.
I have said that.
是的，但我有时说过。我和你一样，威尔。我永远不会拒绝孩子，但有时如果我和家人在一起，我会说，你介意吗？我，我只是，我和家人在一起。对我来说最有趣的是，每次我说不的时候，这非常罕见，人们都接受得很好，因为他们似乎完全理解。所以从某种意义上说，我觉得他们知道他们在要求什么，他们要求的是一点点，某种程度上，拍一张照片需要很多
Yeah, but I've said sometimes.
I'm the same, Will.
I wouldn't ever say no to a child, but sometimes if I'm with the family, I'll say, would you mind awfully?
I, I just, I'm with my family.
And what's so interesting to me is that every time I have said no, and it's quite rare,
people have taken it so well because they seem completely to understand.
So in a way, I feel like they know what they're asking for,
that what they're asking for is a little bit, kind of, it's a lot to take a photograph
和某人在一起。我有一些著名的朋友，他们总是说不。他们从不说 yes。这让我感到非常不舒服，他们就像，我只是觉得那是一团糟。因为这在某种程度上是一个很容易的给予。对。这是一个很容易的给予。你有没有遇到过，嘿，能快速拍张照片吗？
with somebody.
I have some famous friends that they say no all the time.
They never say yes.
And it makes me so uncomfortable that they're like, I just feel like that's a mess.
Because it's such an easy give in a way.
Right.
It's an easy give.
Have you ever gotten, hey, can I get a picture really quick?
然后他们把相机递给你？因为那发生在我身上。对。他们想让你拍一张他们和家人的照片。是的，很多次。我也很多次遇到，哦，天哪，你是，然后他们说了一个完全不同的女演员的名字。
And then they hand you the camera?
Because that's happening to me.
Right.
They want you to take a picture of them with their family.
Yeah.
Many times.
I've also many times got, oh my God, you're,
and then they say the name of a completely different actress.
所以我可以选择。我要么说，是的，我是某某某。我很乐意给你拍张照片。或者我说我年轻20岁，或者我说，或者我老了20岁，或者我说不，她其实已经去世了，但然后我就轻轻地走开了。
So I have the choice.
I either say, yes, I am so-and-so.
I would love to give you a photograph.
or I say I'm 20 years younger
or I say, or I'm 20 years older
or I say no, she's dead actually
but then I just kind of move
gently on through.
你知道什么很有趣吗？前几天我坐在餐厅里，连续发生了两次互动。首先，有个女人走过来，当时我和我姐姐、姐夫以及我们的朋友伊莱，加拿大人伊莱坐在一起，他说，这个女人说，很抱歉打扰你
You know what's funny?
I had the other day I had, I was sitting at a restaurant
and I had two interactions in a row back to back.
First of all, I had a woman come over and say
when I was sitting with my sister and my brother-in-law
and our buddy Eli, Canadian Eli,
and he said, this woman said,
so sorry to bother you
我知道你在吃饭，然后继续坐在我旁边的长椅上开始谈话，当时我就想，好吧，你并没有那么被打扰。她拿了薯条吗？然后她走了，然后另一个女人走过来，她说我的朋友是粉丝
and I know that you're eating
and then proceeded to sit down on the bench next to me
and begin the conversation
at which point I was like well you're not that bothered
Did she grab a fry?
Then she left
and then this other woman came over
and she said my friend is a fan
但我很抱歉，你叫什么名字？伊莱说杰森·贝特曼，她说非常感谢，她走开了。JB，我忘了告诉你，那太好了，那太好了，我有一个非常美妙的
but I'm sorry what's your name
and Eli goes Jason Bateman
she said thank you so much
she walked away
J.B I forgot to tell you that
it was so good
I had a really wonderful
一次。我在威尼斯的哈利酒吧，你知道，那是最初的哈利酒吧，那是一个非常夜晚。那是很多年前的事了，一个女人走过来，她在另一个房间，她不停地对我露出巨大的微笑和咧嘴笑，并挥手。我想，好吧，所以她一定知道我的作品发生了，是吗？这似乎很公平。我在威尼斯。这是电影节，等等。总之，她离开时走过来，说，很高兴在这里见到你。哦，谢谢，心想，为什么？然后她说，你知道，我还在穿那些鞋子。我一直穿它们。
one. I was in Harry's Bar in Venice, which is, you know, the original Harry's Bar, and it was very
night. It was years and years ago, and a woman came up, she was in the other room, and she kept on
peeling off these massive smiles and grins at me and waving. And I thought, okay, so she must
know my work happens, is it? That seems fair enough. I'm in Venice. It's the festival, blah.
Anyway, she came over as she was leaving and said, I'm so happy to see you in here.
Oh, thank you, thinking, why?
And then she said, you know, I still wear those shoes.
I wear them all the time.
我爱它们。你是对的。我错了，你是对的。我在想，鞋子。然后她说，你记得，我盯着她想，我搞不清楚这个。我没拍过关于鞋子的电影。我有吗？
I love them.
You were so right.
I was wrong and you were right.
And I'm thinking, shoes.
And then she said, you remember, I'm staring at her thinking,
I can't work this one out.
I haven't made a film about shoes.
Have I?
总之，她说，你记得巴尼斯百货的五楼吗？所以她以为我在巴尼斯百货的鞋类部门卖给她一双鞋，而她很高兴在哈利酒吧见到我，因为显然这意味着我混得不错。你知道我的意思吗？我就像在同一个领域
Anyway, she said, you remember the fifth floor in Barnys?
So she thought that I'd sold her a pair of shoes
In the shoe department at Barnies
And she was thrilled to see me in Harry's bar
Because clearly that meant I was doing quite well for myself
Do you know what I mean?
That I was like in the same
I was in the same arena
作为一个在巴尼斯百货五楼买鞋的女人，这让她感到高兴，她需要向我传达这一点，我觉得这其实很善良。我说，我很高兴它们还合脚。为你高兴。艾玛，你像我怀念巴尼斯百货一样怀念它吗？
As a woman who buys shoes on the fifth floor at Barneys
And that that gave her pleasure
And she needed to convey that to me
Which was very kind, I thought actually
And I said, I'm so glad they still fit
Good for you
Amma, do you miss Barney's
like I miss Barneys?
我怀念。我非常怀念巴尼斯百货。我们前几天还在谈论，我非常怀念它。我们承认了可怕的肤浅，但我确实怀念。我真的怀念。顺便说一下，纽约和洛杉矶都是。你很难过。
I do.
I miss Barney's a lot.
We were just talking about the other day, I miss it so much.
We were admitting to terrible shallowness,
but I do.
I really do.
By the way, both New York and L.A.
You're sad.
我两个都怀念。是的，两个地方。我喜欢那些地方。我喜欢它们。它怎么了？发生了什么？它怎么会倒闭？是因为人们现在在网上购物，对吧？
I miss them both.
Yeah, both places.
I love those places.
I love them.
What happened to it?
What happened?
How would it go belly up?
It's because people shop online now, right?
是这样吗？是的，是的。所有东西，是的。我得去鞋类，对吧，直接去……那里的鞋类部门。哦，不，你只是走那个人，所以你走那条后路，比如，那是什么，比如15夜街？
Is that right?
Yeah, yeah.
Everything, yeah.
I have to go to the shoe, right, direct to the...
shoe department at the point.
Oh, no, you just walking that man,
so you're walking the back way there on, like, what is that,
like 15-night Street?
你可以走那个后门。我在谈论洛杉矶。市中心也有一个。嗯，最初在17街。是的。哦，伙计们，继续说数字。同样的数字，马克。啊。
You can walk in that back door.
I was talking about Los Angeles.
And there was one downtown, too.
Well, the original on 17th Street.
Yeah.
Oh, guys, keep saying numbers.
Same numbers, Mark.
Ah.
我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。等等，艾玛，所以，听着，让我们回去。让我们回去。让我们回去。我喜欢……让我们开始采访。这是一个问题。
And we will be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Wait, Emma, so, listen, let's go back.
Let's go back.
I love...
Let's start the interview.
This is a question.
这是答案所在。你们。你们，艾玛在这儿。我们是有史以来最糟糕的采访者。我很抱歉。你正在实时意识到这一点。你的后悔显而易见。我们……
This is where the answer.
You guys.
You guys, Emma's here.
We're the worst interviews of all time.
I'm so sorry.
And you're realizing that in real time.
And your regret is evident.
We...
所以我不知道你是……你开始……嗯，我开始了，但你在剑桥著名的Footlight素描小组，那里见证了很多伟大的表演者。所以你有素描喜剧的历史，这太神奇了。我不知道。那很酷。哦，是的。
So I didn't know that you were...
That you started...
Well, I started, but you were in the acclaimed footlight sketch group at Cambridge,
which has seen a lot of great performers.
So you have a history of sketch comedy, which is so amazing.
I didn't know that.
That's cool.
Oh, yeah.
我做了很多年。那会是像英国讽刺剧那样的东西吗？算是吧。在某种程度上相当于讽刺剧。但它更多的是素描。但是，你知道，它就像SNL。SNL基本上是我认为的评论。对。
I did that for years.
Would that be like the British lampoon type of thing?
Sort of, yeah.
It's an equivalent to sort of the lampoon in a way-ish.
But it's more of a sketch.
But, you know, it's like SNL.
SNL is basically what I would think of as review.
Right.
所以回到20世纪初，评论在我们国家非常流行。它基本上是素描、歌曲的集合。你知道，只是一种评论。就像综艺。和一个综艺节目，是的。这就是我们做的。它现在完全死了。
So back in the day, in the early part of the 20th century,
review was huge in our country.
And it was basically a collection of sketches, songs.
You know, just a kind of review.
Like a variety.
And a variety show, yes.
And that's what we did.
It's completely dead now.
我们不再有评论了。但SNL是一种评论形式。它确实是。它是素描、歌曲和音乐。你知道，它是小块的。我绝对是从那时开始做的。和休·劳瑞以及斯蒂芬·弗莱一起。是的。
We don't have review anymore.
But SNL is a form of review.
It really is.
It's sketches and songs and music.
You know, it's little bites.
And I started doing that absolutely.
With Hugh Lorry and Stephen Fry.
Yeah.
做了很多年。事实上，我本来要成为一名喜剧演员。那就是我想做的，因为我崇拜莉莉·汤姆林。我从来不知道。如此之大。她很棒。还有简·瓦格纳，你知道，宇宙中智慧生命的迹象。她所有美丽的角色。
Did it for years.
In fact, I was going to be a comedian.
That was what I wanted to be because I admired Lily Tom.
I never knew that.
So greatly.
She's great.
And Jane Wagner, you know, the signs of intelligent life in the universe.
All of her beautiful characters.
是的，不可思议。我喜欢那个。那就是我想做的职业。但你还在做，因为任何时候只要有一个稍微适合喜剧的角色，你就会抓住它并扩展它，而且每当你选择这样做时，你总是非常搞笑。出色的时机。那种美丽的英式干冷。它只是，哦，太好了。
Yeah, incredible.
I love that.
That's what I wanted to do for a living.
But you are still doing it because anytime there's a character that lends itself even slightly to comedy,
you take that and you expand that and you're always freaking hilarious whenever you choose to be.
Excellent timing.
That beautiful British dryness.
It's just, oh, it's so good.
我本来要问你，这些家伙会取笑我，但我是一个巨大的哈利·波特迷。哦，别开玩笑了。给我们看看魔杖。我没有，我会有。我真的有一根魔杖。但你作为西比尔教授，对吧？西比尔·特里劳妮教授，是的。
I was going to ask you, these guys are going to make fun of me,
but I'm a massive Harry Potter fan.
Oh, no kidding.
Show us the wand.
I don't, I'm going to have it.
I really do have a wand.
But you as Professor Sibyl, right?
Professor Sibble Shulorloor, yeah.
是的。那是……她说，疲惫。谈论，比如，角色和，比如莉莉·汤姆林和简，以及所有那些莉莉·汤姆林的事情，当我看到它时，那是一个，这是一个恭维，
Yeah.
That was...
She said, fatigued.
Speaking about, like, characters and, like,
Lilletamlin and Jane,
and all those things that Let Tomlin,
when I saw that it was such a,
and this is a compliment,
在一个有大角色的世界里，这是一个大角色，你们，如果你们没看过，她戴着像可乐瓶底一样的眼镜，字面上这么厚，让她的眼球变得这么大。而且她神经质，她会被附身。这是一个如此不可思议的角色。你怎么相信那是，你第一天进来的选择，
such a big character in a world that has big characters
with the, you guys, if you haven't seen it,
she has like Coke bottle glasses, like literally this thick
that make her eyeballs this big.
And she's neurotic and she gets possessed.
And it's such an incredible character.
How did you trust that that was,
that your choice to come in on the first day,
我们谈论这个，很多。带着巨大的摇摆。这是一个巨大的摇摆，你怎么相信那个？你真的不怎么做。你是怎么想出这个角色的？嗯，书里写着。她有那些眼镜？
we talk about this, a lot of them.
With a huge swing.
Which a huge swing was going to be,
how did you trust that?
You don't really do.
How did you come up with the character?
Well, it's written in the books.
That she has those glasses?
我想她绝对是近乎失明。什么也看不见。而且显然非常神经质，因为她有时能看到人们是否，你知道，有厄运。所以，我是说，老实说，在我相当长的职业生涯中，考虑到我比你们所有人都大10岁，
I think she's definitely nearly blind.
Can't see anything.
And obviously deeply neurotic
because she can see sometimes
whether people are, you know, have the grim or not.
So, I mean, honestly, in my quite long career,
given the fact that I'm good 10 years older
than all of you guys,
我演过很多很多角色。我一生中在《哈利·波特》上花了大约30天。所以谈论这个有点奇怪，因为它已经变成了这样，这是一个巨大的现象。而且很多时候人们非常被那个所吸引。人们停下来，是的。我是说，我也，我也看过《大梦想家》20次，我看过《理智与情感》和《长日留痕》。
I have done many, many parts.
and I've spent about 30 days on Harry Potter in my whole life.
So it's kind of a strange thing to talk about because it's become such,
this is this huge phenomenon.
And that's a lot of the time that's what people are very sort of drawn to that.
People stop, yeah.
I mean, I'm also, I've also seen saving Mr. Banks like 20 times,
and I've seen sensibility and remains of the day.
不，不，我不是针对你。是的，是的。只是……只是为了确保。你知道那是什么感觉，伙计们，当你决定扮演某人时。你只需要把自己投入进去，不是吗？是的。并希望你的直觉是正确的。
No, no, I wasn't getting at you.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just that...
Just to make sure.
You know what it's like, guys, when you decide to play someone.
You just have to fling yourself into it, don't you?
Yeah.
And hope that your instincts are right.
是的。嗯，总是有那种东西。因为我们谈论那个想法。你知道，我总是说这就像当你第一次到达并做某事时，你做了一个选择，你想确保你的音量和别人不一样，特别是如果你中途进来。这就是我说的。
Yeah.
Well, there's always that thing.
Because we talk about that idea.
You know, I always say it's like when you first arrive and you're doing something,
you've made a sort of a choice,
and you want to make sure that you're not at a different volume than everybody else,
especially if you come in in the middle.
That's what I'm saying.
你知道我的意思吗？你就像……是的，是的，是的。那是真的。这是，你知道？我在拍另一部电影吗？是的，我在拍另一部电影吗？我进来了，我今年冬天做了点什么，我有点进来了。
You know what I mean?
And you're like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true.
Is this, you know?
Am I in a different movie?
Yeah, am I in a different movie?
I came in, I did something this winter, and I sort of came in.
他们已经工作了一段时间，我想，哦，男孩，我有一个真正的造型。我想，一个真正的。那个造型是什么，那个造型是什么？他有点像个退休的摇滚乐手，他有点运气不好。佩德罗·帕斯卡进来了，他是我的兄弟。我只是，就像，我有点和导演托尼·吉尔罗伊一起研究它，我想，就是这个。但与此同时，我想，就像，你知道，那一刻，就像，
They'd been working for a while, and I thought, like, oh boy, and I had a real look going.
And I thought, at a real.
What was the look, what was the look?
He was sort of like a retired rocker, and he's sort of down on his luck.
And Pedro Pascal comes in, and he's my brother.
And I just, like, and I sort of worked on it with the director with Tony Gilroy, and I thought,
this is it. But at the same time, I thought, like,
you know, that first moment, like,
开始了，伙计们，我们正在录。我像，男孩，有更好的工作。是的。这太可怕了。但至少托尼见过它。是的，他见过。我们谈论过它。但仍然，我们还没做。你知道我的意思吗？所以你没有机会排练，像我们一样。这在电影中相当罕见，不是吗，你有机会排练？是的。而在剧院，你知道，一切都是关于排练。
here we go, guys, and we're rolling. I'm like, boy,
there's better work. Yeah. It's so scary. But at least Tony had
seen it. Yes, he had. We had talked about it.
But still, we hadn't done it.
Do you know what I mean? So you don't get to rehearse, like us.
It's quite rare, isn't it, in film, that you get to rehearse?
Yeah.
Whereas in theater, you know, it's all about rehearsal.
是的。一切都是关于排练。我喜欢它。所以有时我觉得很遗憾我们没有进入。我们在电影里没有足够的排练。但是，你知道，再次，拍摄是一个非常神秘的生意。它是。你永远不知道会出来什么，而且摄像机太奇怪了，你不觉得吗？我发现它有一种巫术般的存在。
Yeah. All about rehearsal.
I love it.
So sometimes I think it's a shame we don't get in.
we don't get enough rehearsal in-thole.
But, you know, again, it's a very mysterious business filming.
It is.
You never know what's going to come out, and the camera's so odd, don't you think?
A bit of a sort of witchy presence, I find.
嗯，你也有那种当你完成某事时，人们说，怎么样？你就像，我不知道。是的。你知道，那是在等待的时期。而且，JB，显然，当你在后期制作并且你在把电影放在一起时，你和它生活在一起。它一直和你一起呼吸。
Well, you also have that thing when you finish something and you go, and people say,
how was it?
You're like, I don't know.
Yeah.
You know, that's sort of in that period of waiting.
And, J.B., obviously, when you're in post and you're putting a film together,
you're living with it.
it's breathing with you all the time.
所以，就像，你对它有一种感觉。但其他人都会离开。是的，真的总是。艾玛，你做过导演。是的？不？不。我从来没导过。
And so, like, you have a sense of it.
But everybody else kind of goes away.
Yeah, there really is always.
Emma, you've done some directing.
Yes?
No?
No.
I've never directed.
你没有吗？不。为什么我觉得你导过几次？但那里只是那个。你为什么没导过？让我们逼她。艾玛，你能检查一下你没导过吗？是的，检查。
Have you not?
No.
Why did I feel like you had a couple of times?
But there is just that.
Why haven't you?
Let's press her.
Can you, Emma, can you check that you haven't?
Yeah, check.
我们会等。我们会等。我干涉了很多。那不是。导演。那只是以一种稍微令人不安的方式参与。特别是，我想，在有孩子的电影里，我花了很多时间和孩子们在一起，因为那很重要。我为年轻人拍的电影，
We'll wait.
I've interfered a massive amount.
That's not.
directing though. That's just taking part in a slightly upsetting way.
Especially with, I suppose, with the films with children in,
I've spent a lot of time with the children because that's important.
And the films I've made for young people,
我总是认为孩子是神圣的观众。他们是我们最需要为之做出最好作品的人。而且他们不说谎。这是他们第一次看到某样东西。它需要非常，非常。天哪，你在这么多流派中做了这么多事情。当你谈论像儿童电影之类的东西，以及这么多事情，我只是，我只是，
I always consider children to be the sacred audience.
They're the people we need to make the best of our work for.
And they don't lie.
It's the first time that they see something.
It needs to be so, so.
God, you've done so many things over so many genres.
When you're speaking of like the children's films and stuff,
and so many things, and I was just, I was just,
我在过去一年里看了一部你几年前拍的电影，哦，天哪，大概10年前，但它是基于我最喜欢的书之一，也就是《柏林孤影》。哦，天哪，你看了那个。你就像三个人中的一个。当然。那本书对我来说太不可思议了。
I watched within the last year,
a film that you did a few years ago,
oh God, probably 10 years ago,
but it's based on one of my favorite books of all time,
which is Alone in Berlin.
Oh my God, you saw that.
You were like one of three people.
Of course. That book was incredible to me.
哦，我喜欢那本书。它是其中之一，它只是一本如此惊人的书。它是我读过的最好的书的后半部分之一。它只是令人着迷。然后我意识到我拍了一部电影。所以我不知道你拍了那部电影。我看了它。
Oh, I love that book.
It's one of,
It's just such an amazing book.
It's one of the best second halves of a book I've ever read.
It's just mesmerizing.
And so then I realized I made a film.
So I didn't know that you had made that film.
And I watched it.
它很美。它很可爱。这是一个如此伟大的故事。这是一个二战故事吗？它是。它几乎是一件抵抗艺术作品，书在电影里是这样。你怎么，因为你在这么多不同的流派中做这些事情，比如你怎么决定拍一部像电影一样的电影，
It was beautiful.
It was lovely.
It's such a great story.
Is it a World War II story?
It is.
It's almost a piece of resistance art in a way the book is in the film.
And how do you, because you do these things across so many different genres,
like how do you decide to do like a film like a film like a,
在柏林，让我们说，但只是举个例子，它总是基于材料，还是你生命中某个时刻的感觉，你就像，我想做一些有点情绪化的事情，或者你是怎么处理那个过程的？我想你是对的。我想这有点像在正确的时间遇到正确的人，或者在正确的时间读到正确的书。
in Berlin, let's say, but just for instance,
is it always just material-based
or how you're feeling at a certain time in your life
and you're like, I want to do something that's kind of moody
or how do you go about that process?
I think you're right.
I think it's a little bit like meeting the right person
at the right time or reading the right book at the right time.
事情在你可能需要它们的时候来到你身边。我想作为艺术家，有时我们需要扮演某些东西，它只是向我们走来。我是说，我想这一切都在那里，一直围绕着我们移动。然后事情从我们身边经过，我们想，哦，我希望我能。哦，好吧，其实，不，那是错的。
Things come to you at moments when perhaps you need them.
I think as artists, sometimes we need to play certain things,
it's just coming at us.
I mean, I think it's all sort of out there,
moving around us all the time.
And then things pass us by and we think,
oh, I wish I could have.
Oh, well, actually, no, that was wrong.
然后某样东西进来，击中我们的中心。你就像，我现在真的想讲那个故事。有时你不知道为什么，但我总是知道如果那是我想要做的事情。我总是知道。而且它甚至不是，它不是我能量化的东西，以任何有用的方式量化。它字面上是某样东西会穿过我的浴缸，我就像，哦，哦，那是一个美妙的故事。
And then something comes in
and hits us right in the centre of us.
And you go, I really want to tell that story now.
And sometimes you don't know why,
but I always know if it's something I want to do.
I always know.
And it's not even, it's not something I could quantify, quantify in any useful way.
It's literally something will come across my bath and I go, oh, oh, that's a wonderful story.
然后有些东西出现，正好击中了我们的内心。你会觉得，我现在真的很想讲那个故事。有时你不知道为什么，但我总是知道那是不是我想做的事。我总是知道。这甚至不是我能以任何有用的方式量化的东西。它纯粹就是某件事出现在我的生活中，然后我就想，哦，那是一个很棒的故事。
I mean, alone in Berlin is, I mean, I'm kind of slightly obsessed with both wars, actually,
because I think they left traumas in our country in the UK that have never really been healed or addressed.
and so alone in Berlin for me is just this beautiful
I mean the book is incredible if you haven't read it, do.
It's Hafner, isn't it? It's his pseudonym, isn't it, Will?
Sebastian Hafner.
Hans Falada? Hans Falada, yeah, and his actual name is perhaps the other one.
I get that when I...
我的意思是，《柏林孤影》这本书，其实我对两次世界大战都有些着迷，因为我觉得它们在英国留下了从未真正治愈或解决的创伤。所以对我来说，《柏林孤影》非常美，如果你还没读过这本书，一定要读。是哈夫纳写的，对吧？那是他的笔名，对吧，威尔？塞巴斯蒂安·哈夫纳。汉斯·法拉达？汉斯·法拉达，没错，他真实的名字可能是另一个。当我……的时候我就会想到这个。
Sean, you go get a snack, but...
Three stooges, right, Sean, when that came,
Yeah.
Alma, have you ever taken apart a character, said yes to it?
Because that character has sort of a personality trait that you are thinking seriously about expanding in your own life.
And this might be a fun way to kind of play a little bit with that and try it on and maybe incorporate some of it at the end if it goes well.
Because I've done that a couple of times.
That's really interesting.
肖恩，你去拿点零食，但是……“三个臭皮匠”，对吧，肖恩，当那个出现的时候。是的。阿尔玛，你有没有拆解过一个角色，并答应出演？因为那个角色有一种你正认真考虑在自己生活中扩展的人格特质。这可能是一种有趣的方式，可以稍微尝试一下，穿上它，如果进展顺利的话，也许最后会融入一些。因为我这样做过几次。那真的很有趣。
Really?
like you're like I want to be like I'm going to play this
smarty pants because I'd like
I'd like to be a little bit more like like like
like how I'm kind of reading this character
in this in this script and this would be a kind
of an easy little cheat
to try it off is that DTF?
真的吗？就像你觉得“我想成为那样的人”，所以我打算扮演这个聪明人，因为我想让自己变得更像我在剧本里读到的这个角色，这会是一个尝试改变的简单小窍门，这是“准备好做那事”吗？
Yeah but
but like yeah sometimes it's for the
for the director or the story
or the other cast or whatever but then sometimes
it's it's oh I kind of always
wanted to be kind of like that and
maybe I'll try a little bit here
have you ever done that? I think I
是的，但有时候是为了导演、故事、其他演员什么的，但有时是因为“哦，我一直想成为那样的人”，也许我会在这里尝试一下。你做过吗？我想我
did that with Down Cemetery Road. I did a telly recently. It's a series called Down Cemetery Road,
which is a quote from a Philip Larkin poem. And it's a Mick Herron book. It's the Slow Horses
group. And I think I, I mean, not only do I love the author, but the character,
she's sort of my age, probably grew up in London during the slightly seamy 60s. I mean,
as a child in the 60s, you know,
I think about my childhood in London,
how really close
to the end of the war that was.
在《墓地路》里做过。我最近拍了一部电视剧。剧名是《墓地路》，引用自菲利普·拉金的一首诗。那是米克·赫伦的书。就是《流人》那个系列的作者。我想，不仅是因为我喜欢这位作者，还因为这个角色，她和我年纪差不多，可能是在伦敦那段稍微有些混乱的60年代长大的。我的意思是，作为60年代的孩子，你知道，我想到我在伦敦的童年，那离战争结束其实非常近。
I mean, I was born in 1959,
so it was 14 years after the end of the Second World War.
It's nothing really.
It's like a blink of an eye.
And therefore...
Still rebuilding.
Yeah. Oh, God, yes, absolutely.
And still to a certain extent,
我的意思是，我出生于1959年，也就是第二次世界大战结束14年后。那真的不算什么。就像眨眼之间。因此……还在重建中。是的，天哪，当然。而且在某种程度上，
a little bit of, you know,
not having quite enough to eat.
and it was, I think, quite dark probably,
which is one of the reasons why alone in Berlin was interesting for me as well.
But I think that this character, Zoe, is not a good girl.
I was brought up to be very good, very obedient, very, not in a bad way,
but in a way that I think that many, many girls in my culture are brought up
to be always lovely and kind and loving and emolient and accepting and tolerant.
还有一点，你知道，食物不太充足。而且我想，那段时期可能相当黑暗，这也是《柏林孤影》对我来说很有趣的原因之一。但我认为这个角色，佐伊，不是个“乖乖女”。我从小被教育要非常乖、非常顺从，不是说不好，而是我觉得在我这种文化背景下，很多很多女孩从小就被教育要总是可爱、善良、充满爱心、温和、包容且宽容。
And I think that whilst there is a place for that in both sexes,
it is not appropriate for it to be just women who do that,
and nor is it sometimes appropriate for them to do it at all.
So, you know, actually this,
woman doesn't do it in any way.
She just, she's a very releasing sort of character because she's unapologetic and certainly not
polite.
And whilst she has kindness, certainly an empathy inside her, she uses it very judiciously
我认为虽然男女都有这种特质的一席之地，但仅仅由女性来承担是不合适的，而且有时她们根本就不该这样做。所以，你知道，实际上这个女人一点也不那样做。她是一个非常让人解脱的角色，因为她从不道歉，也绝对不客气。虽然她内心确实有善良和同理心，但她使用得非常审慎，
and not, as it were, just as a kind of scattergun technique to avoid conflict.
or being judged for not being, you know, a nice woman.
Sure.
Does she weaponize it?
What do you mean?
Like uses it, like it's calculated the way it's used or no?
No, it's quite natural.
It's quite natural.
而不是像那种为了避免冲突或因为不够“好女人”而被评判而采取的散弹枪式策略。当然。她会把这种特质武器化吗？你是什么意思？就像利用它，比如使用时是经过计算的，还是不？不，这很自然。这很自然。
It's not really a, it's just an instinct.
She's just managed.
Like I always feel when Sean's being kind of me,
is just manipulating me, you know what I mean?
Well, that's true, I think.
Yeah.
I mean, I think you're right about that.
Wait, Emma, you grew up, I was just thinking, so both your, as you talk about this,
这真的不是……这只是一种本能。她只是处理得很好。就像我总觉得肖恩对我好的时候，只是在操纵我，你明白我的意思吗？嗯，我想你是对的。是的。我的意思是，我觉得你说得对。等等，艾玛，你长大的时候，我刚才在想，所以你的父母，如果我说错了请纠正我，都是演员，对吧？嗯，嗯，是的。是的，所以你是在……你是在演艺世家长大的，对吧？是的，我是，但那是戏剧的家族生意。是的。所以我的父母成长的年代，那时真的没有电视。所以他们作为演员自然而然地期望
and both your parents, correct me if I'm wrong, were actors, is that right?
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, yeah.
Yeah, so you grew up, like, this is a sort of a, you grew up in the family biz in a way,
is that right?
Yes, I did, but it was the family business of theater.
Yeah.
So my parents grew up at a time when there really was no television.
So they expected naturally as actors
我的父亲是来自我们吉尔福德南部城镇的工人阶级，没受过多少教育，非常自学成才，决定成为一名演员并离开那个地方。我的意思是，他彻底摆脱了他出身的一切。你知道他的母亲，我的祖母，
My father was working class
from a southern town in our guildford
Had not very much education
Was very self-taught
Decided to become an actor
And leave that patch
I mean he was a proper lever of everything that he came from
You know his mother, my grandmother
是个仆人。她16岁就开始做佣人，而且她确实有一个孩子是未婚生下的，因为她被雇主强奸了。所以她作为四个孩子的母亲的旅程确实相当戏剧性。爸爸走出来了，进入了戏剧界，遇到了我母亲，她来自苏格兰，文化和背景非常不同。苏格兰长老会教徒，所以非常……人们其实很清教徒。是的。
Was a servant
She went into service when she was 16 years old
old and and indeed one of her children was born out of wedlock because she was raped by one of
her employers so her journey as a mother with these four children was really quite dramatic and
dad got out and went into the theatre and met my mother who's from Scotland very different
culture and background Presbyterians Scottish Presbyterian so very well people
Puritanical actually.
Yeah.
一个人真的无法避免这一点，尽管她从未能抵挡住好酒的诱惑，这很棒。但你知道，确实有……我确实是在这种非常有趣的组合中长大的。但他们做戏剧，他们期望在各省演莎士比亚，
One can't really avoid that,
even though she's never been
able to resist good wine,
which is excellent.
But you know, there was,
I did grow up with this very interesting sort of combination.
But they did theatre,
and they expected to do Shakespeare in the provinces
然后是广播，接着电视出现了。我们没有电视，直到我，我不知道，八岁，而且是黑白的。嗯。你知道，我们不那样做，我们没有那个。
and then radio,
and then television arrived.
We didn't have a television,
until I was, I don't know, eight
and it was black and white.
Mm-hmm.
You know, we didn't do that,
we didn't have that.
而现在，太不一样了。是的。实际上，这简直难以形容地奇怪。你是说那些用来分散你注意力的内容量吗？某种程度上，是它的广度。是的，是的。而且必须生产的数量。
And now, it's so different.
Yeah.
It's kind of indescribably strange, actually.
You mean the amount of content that's out there
to distract you by?
The breadth of it all, sort of, in a way.
Yeah, yeah.
And the amount that must be produced.
对。你对你的孩子有什么政策？你是那种觉得屏幕没问题、电视没问题、iPad没问题的人，还是说“不，必须是阅读或钢琴课”，因为我是在那种家庭长大的，非常、非常纪律严明，尽管电视也很多。这算是一种组合。
Right.
What was your policy with your kids?
Did you, were you, were you,
you someone that was, screens are okay, television's okay, iPads are okay,
or were you like, no, it's reading or it's piano lessons or it's,
because I grew up at one of those households, very, very disciplined,
although there was plenty of TV too.
It was kind of a combo.
我想这是一个很好的组合。我们告诉女儿电视坏了，她至少信了八年。还在坏着。还在坏着。然后她在九岁左右跳着进来，说：“我修好它了！”她只是找到了该死的遥控器。总之，我们不允许她有手机，
It was a good combo, I think.
We told my daughter the television was broken, which she believed for at least eight years.
Still broken.
It's still broken.
And then she danced in at the age of about nine
and said, I've mended it!
She just found the sodding remote.
Anyway, and we didn't allow her to have a phone
直到她上中学，13岁的时候。是的，聪明。所以iPad，天哪，有时候我们开车时，我们也住在苏格兰，我们开车去苏格兰，iPad是个好东西。你需要放部电影。然后他们就能看，
until she was at secondary school at the age of 13.
Yeah, smart.
So iPads, oh God, sometimes when we were driving,
we live in Scotland as well,
we were driving to Scotland,
and iPad was a wonderful thing.
You need a film on.
And then they could watch.
一部电影，其实我对此并不感到内疚。如果是一部好电影，那是度过两小时的美好方式。因为我过去常常被困在车里八个小时，开车去苏格兰，除了盯着路过的灯柱发呆和做些糟糕的……但这对想象力有好处，
a film, which actually
I don't feel guilty about it. If it's a good
film, it's a lovely way
to spend two hours. Because I used to be stuck in
the car for eight hours as we were driving to Scotland
with nothing to do but stare at the lamp
post going by and do
terrible sort of... But it's good for the imagination
真的。真的很好。想想那些小时。而且无聊对想象力也有好处，威尔。我和肖恩是朋友。我们已经失去了与“无聊”的关系。管理无聊是一种天赋。好了，这是我的问题。问你们所有人，你们上一次真正感到无聊是什么时候。
though. It's really good. Think about all those hours.
And boredom's good for the imagination as well, Will.
I'm friends with Sean. We've lost our
relationship with being bored.
Managing boredom is a talent.
Okay, here's my question.
To all of you, when was the last time
you were actually bored.
这个周末。真的吗？为什么？怎么会？嗯，只是因为我一直待在室内，外面在下雨，而且我没好电视看了。我做完了所有的家庭作业。但你猜后来发生了什么？
This weekend.
Really?
Why?
How?
Well, just because I was inside the whole time, it was raining,
and I ran out of a good TV.
I had done all my homework.
But then guess what happens?
你变得真正放松了。我真的觉得真正的放松就住在无聊的隔壁，那是小睡发生的时候，也是头脑清醒、所有优先级都理顺的时候。你可以思考什么是好的……这太棒了，管理无聊、拥抱无聊、看到无聊的优点，是我觉得我的孩子们、他们那一代人……不理解或不熟悉的东西。他们甚至不能坐电梯，
You get truly relaxed.
I really feel like true relaxation lives somewhere next door to boredom,
and that's when naps happen,
and clarity of mind,
and all your priorities get in the right order.
and you can think about what's kind like it's a great managing boredom embracing boredom
seeing the virtues of boredom is something that I just don't think that my my kids their
generation is uh is understands or is is friends with they can't even write an elevator
而不看手机。是的，是的，是的，是的。我实际上……我实际上在不同的时候对我两个儿子说过，你不能看着手机走下楼梯。那必须是独立于手机的事情。这太荒谬了。但我会说，你知道吗？我最近和朋友谈过这个。我从不无聊。即使我只是坐在那里，我也不知道为什么。
without looking at their phone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i've actually i've actually said to
my both of my sons at various points you cannot walk down the stairs looking at your phone
That has to be something that is independent of your phone.
This is absurd.
But I will say, you know what?
I was talking about this with a friend recently.
I'm never bored.
Even if I'm just sitting there, I don't know why.
我从不感到无聊。对，我不是贬义。我只是觉得……就像你不是……我们所有人，我觉得当今世界上大多数人都是高度运转的，就像我们只是……因为全球生产力，同时处理50件不同的事情。但有一个伟大的……
I never feel bored.
Right, I don't mean it as a pejorative.
I just feel like it.
It's like you're not, we're all so, I think most people in the world today
are highly functioning, like we're just like,
to manage 50 different things at the same time
just because of just sort of global productivity.
But there is a great...
天哪，你总是谈论生产力。这太不可思议了。你从不回避生产力。肖恩，我刚才在想，肖恩，我想知道……当你听到艾玛谈论在戏剧界长大和她的父母……顺便说一句，你好，肖恩，欢迎来到播客。非常感谢邀请我。
God, you're always talking about productivity.
It's unbelievable.
You never shy away from productivity.
Sean, I was just thinking, Sean, I wonder...
When you hear Emma talk about growing up in the theater
and her parents...
Hi, Sean, by the way, welcome to the podcast.
Thank you so much for having me.
我是你们的超级粉丝。你是否希望，在某种程度上，当你听到那些在戏剧界长大的人时，你知道，你有多享受那个，你有没有觉得，哦，我希望我是在那种环境中长大的？是的，一直都这么想。真的吗？就像，甚至杰森，比如，成长过程中。
I'm such big fans.
Do you wish, in a way, when you hear about people
who grew up in the theater and stuff,
Do you feel, knowing your, you know, how much you enjoy that,
do you ever feel like, oh, I wish I'd grown up in that kind of environment?
Yeah, all the time.
Do you?
Like, well, even Jason, like, growing up.
在好莱坞周围长大，或者艾玛在其中长大，你知道，什么？肖恩，你是从什么时候开始的？是高中，对吧？是的，是的，高中，嗯，初中。我，我在后台工作，我负责灯光，不是灯光。只有一个灯。而且是。是的，只有一个开关。
Growing up around Hollywood and in it, or Emma growing up in it, you know, like, what?
When did it start for you, Sean?
It was high school, right?
Yeah, yeah, high school, well, junior high.
I was, I worked backstage, I worked the light, not the light.
It was just one light.
And it was.
Yeah, it was one switch.
说真的，就是开和关。而且是，夹子。我们的人。我们有我们的人。我当时想，我想我能做到。那是《灾星珍妮》，音乐剧《灾星珍妮》。哦，是的。是的，那是初中，然后是高中。然后我当时很紧张，不敢告诉家人我在演戏，因为它和体育不挂钩。我想，他们会怎么想？所以我的大哥说，嘿，伙计，没关系，兄弟。就像，我踢足球。我眼睛下面涂了化妆品，眼睛下面的黑印。就像，你涂化妆品。我当时想，哦，那真贴心。然后发生了其他事情。
Seriously, it was on and off.
And it was, clamp.
our guy. We got our guy. I was like, I think I can do that. And it was Calamity Jane, the musical
Calamity Jane. Oh, yeah. And yeah, that was junior high, and then high school. And then I was
nervous about telling my family I was in theater because it wasn't associated with sports. And I thought,
what were they going to think? And so my oldest brother was like, hey, dude, it's okay, bro. Like,
I play football. I have makeup on underneath my eyes, the black marks underneath my eyes.
Just like, you wear makeup. And I was like, oh, that's really sweet. And then other things happened.
好吧，我们别谈那个了。但是的，我总是，你知道，我，我不知道我是否还喜欢做那个。我的意思是，戏剧的磨练是某种东西，对吧，艾玛，你必须……那种对你的身体和大脑的重复是某种你别无选择只能因为耐力而不得不放弃的东西。我们马上回来。回到节目。艾玛，你参与的最后一部戏剧作品是什么？因为你做过太多了。
Well, let's not get into that.
But yeah, I always, you know, I was, I don't know that I love to do it anymore.
I mean, the grind of theater is something, right, Emma, that you just have to,
that the repetition on your body and your brain is something you kind of have no choice but to outgrow because of the endurance.
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
What was the last theater production you were part of, Emma?
because you've done so many.
嗯，其实我没有。我大部分时间都在拍电影。但我做的最后一件事是我，再次，你知道我们刚才谈论的那些你无法拒绝的事情。他们让我做《理发师陶德》。史蒂夫·桑德海姆的《理发师陶德》，和布林·特菲尔一起，我们和纽约爱乐乐团一起演的，
Well, I haven't actually.
I've mostly done film.
But the last thing I did was something I, again,
you knew we were talking earlier
about things that you just can't say no to.
They asked me to do Sweeney Todd.
Steve Sondheim, Sweeney Todd with Bryn Terfel,
and we did it with the New York Philharmonic
在林肯中心。哇。我们在那里演了五场，然后我们在多米尼恩剧院演了两周。这是什么时候？多酷啊。可能是10年前吧。哦，哇，哇。
at the Lincoln Center.
Wow.
We did five performances there,
and then we did two weeks at the Dominion here.
When was this?
How cool.
It was 10 years ago maybe.
Oh, wow, wow.
是的，而且……你会很棒的，我相信你当时表现得非常出色。这对你来说是个完美的角色。绝对是。你是说那个杀人并把他们做成馅饼的心理变态女人吗？不，快，快。肖恩，肖恩，肖恩。哦，天哪。
Yeah, and...
You'd be great, and I'm sure you were phenomenal.
It's a perfect part for you.
Absolutely.
You mean the psychotic, like, woman who kills people and puts them into highs.
No, quick, quick.
Sean, Sean, Sean.
Oh, my, God.
你得让肖恩说完，艾玛。不，它的喜剧效果。我相信你演得很好。不，我相信我当时，做得太过火了。但总之，重点是，我们在舞台上，和纽约爱乐乐团一起。我真正喜欢的一点是不同艺术形式的交叉授粉，
You've got to let Sean finish, Emma.
No, the comedy of it.
I'm sure you nailed it.
No, I'm sure I was, did way too, went way too far.
But anyway, the point was, we were on stage,
with the New York Philharmonic.
And one of the things that really I loved about it
was the sort of cross-pollination of different art forms
你有一个完整的管弦乐队在舞台上，你可以和他们一起表演。所以，你知道，你在表演时，定音鼓手就在你身后制造这些惊人的声音。他们也喜欢这样。管弦乐队很喜欢它，因为你就在他们中间。而且我认为我们把音乐，特别是古典音乐，和戏剧表演隔离开了，你知道，这有时会，让人觉得有点优越感，
that you had a whole orchestra on stage that you could act with.
So, you know, you were acting while the timponist was behind you
making these amazing noises.
And they loved it as well.
The orchestra adored it because you were in amongst them.
And I think that we silo music, classical music in particular,
and acting in the theatre, you know, which sometimes can,
and just make people feel a little bit superior,
事实并非如此。这只是戏剧表演。然后是电视表演，那是电视表演。你必须对摄像机非常聪明。如果你是个好演员，你就是个好演员，无论你在做什么。我喜欢这个。
which is not the case.
It's just acting in the future.
And then there's television acting,
which is television acting.
You've got to be really clever with the cameras.
If you're a good actor, you're a good actor, you're a good actor,
whatever you're doing.
I love that.
我受不了那种势利，在我父母那个年代非常盛行。所以，是的，那是我的最后一部作品。而且我，哦，我的意思是，那是一种惊人的感觉。就像，我不知道你们有没有过这种经历，但当你做一件用尽你每一个细胞的事情时，什么都不会留下。你知道你怎么能上场，特别是做一个短期的工作，
I can't bear all that snobbery,
which was very much alive when my parents were coming up.
So, yeah, that was the last thing I did.
And I, oh, I mean, it was an amazing feeling.
like, I don't know whether you guys have ever had this,
but when you do something that uses every single cell of you,
nothing is left behind.
You know how you can come on, particularly to do a job that's a short job
你演一个小角色或客串角色，你只用了你的一小部分功力，你必须小心不要做得太过。这非常符合你的观点，肖恩，关于特里劳妮教授。那必须是一个非常具体、微小的事情，而且必须是正确的，但也必须是宏大的。但这必须是正确的。它必须是巨大的。
and you're doing a small part or a cameo role,
and you're using a tiny little bit of your palate,
and you have to be careful not to overdo it.
That's very much to your point, Sean, about Professor Trilorni.
It had to be a very specific, small thing,
and it had to be right, but it had to be big as well.
But this had to be right.
It had to be enormous.
它用尽了我所拥有的一切。我做的时候度过了一段非常美妙的时光。但天哪，它是……那太累人了。我花了九个月才学会它。然后我演了大约30场。是的，我听说桑德海姆几乎和莎士比亚一样难，对吧？有时。
And it used absolutely everything I had.
And I had such a wonderful time doing it.
But my God, it was...
That's exhausting.
It took me nine months to learn it.
And then I did it for like 30 performances.
Yeah, I hear Sonheim is almost as difficult to Shakespeare, right?
Sometimes.
我的意思是，你还有音乐部分。是的，找到那些音符和和弦真的很难。我会说更难，是的。比莎士比亚难。莎士比亚让我们变得容易。他就像一艘美妙的旧帆船，你可以进去，直接驶向日落。真的吗？
I mean, you've got the music part of it as well.
Yeah, finding those notes and those chords is really hard.
I would say harder, yeah.
Harder than Shakespeare.
Shakespeare makes it easy for us.
He's like a wonderful old sailing boat you can get into
and just sail into the sunset.
Really?
因为他太可靠了。嗯，说到写作，你，我提到你是唯一获得表演和写作奖项的演员，你写了《理智与情感》，那是怎么发生的？我也不知道，所以知道这一点很高兴。简·奥斯汀写的。是的，是的，是的。我无情地剽窃了。
Because he's so reliable.
Well, speaking of writing, you, I mentioned that you're the only
performer to have won for acting and writing,
and you wrote sense and sensibility, and how did that happen?
I didn't know that either, and so it's delightful to know it.
Jane Austen wrote it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've plagiarized mercilessly.
是的。哦，这不是广播。不，不。但那是怎么发生的，伟大的李安，对吧，导演？和伟大的李安？其实发生得很有趣，因为，就像我过去常做喜剧，那是我的专长，那是我想要做的。而且我很幸运，因为我和一位出色的喜剧制片人合作过。
Yeah.
Oh, it's not a radio.
No, no.
But how did that happen with the Great Ang Lee, right, directed?
With the Great Ang Lee?
Actually, it happened kind of interestingly because, like I used to do comedy,
that was my thing, that is what I wanted to do.
And I was very lucky because I worked with a wonderful comedy producer.
他制作了英国第一部全黑人喜剧系列《德斯蒙德》。然后他与很多黑人、亚裔和女性喜剧演员合作，我想，他在那个意义上相当具有革命性。我和他一起制作了一个喜剧系列。我写的其中一个短剧是关于一个年轻女子从蜜月回来见她母亲，心里有事。她开始和她母亲谈论一个生活在她丈夫胯下的小毛茸茸生物，他曾多次引起注意，
He produced the first all-black comedy series in the UK, Desmond's.
And then he worked with an awful lot of black and Asian and female comedians,
He was, I suppose, quite revolutionary in that sense.
And I made a comedy series with him.
And one of the sketches I wrote was about a young woman coming back from her honeymoon
to see her mother with something on her mind.
And she starts to talk to her mother about a small little woodland hairy creature
that lives in her husband's lap that he's drawn attention to on several occasions
看起来是附着的，有时还会改变形状，所以她只是不想碰它或和它有任何关系。所以这个短剧是关于性无知的。所以这是一个女权主义短剧，关于女性不被允许了解性，但她们却被送进了……
that appears to be attached
and also changes shape sometimes
so that she just doesn't want to touch
or have anything to do with.
And so the sketch is about sexual ignorance.
So it's a feminist sketch
about the fact that women weren't allowed to know about sex
but then they were just sent off into the while.
她们在没有任何帮助的情况下被嫁出去了。你能想象第一次看到阴茎，然后看着它在你眼前勃起，却不知道那是什么吗？这就是我们让人们经历的事情。总之，这个短剧就是关于那个的。而且我觉得它相当有趣。我们的制片人，琳赛·杜兰，
They were married off without any kind of help whatsoever.
And can you imagine coming across a penis for the first time
and then seeing it become erect in front of your very eyes
and not know what it was.
That's what we put people through.
Anyway, so the sketch was about that.
And I think it was quite funny.
And our producer, Lindsay Duran,
那位非凡的好莱坞制片人，她实际上是从《摇滚万万岁》开始她的工作的，抱歉，这简直是我最喜欢的电影之一。当然，当然。所以她写信给我说，我看了你关于维多利亚时代阴茎的短剧。我想知道你是否有兴趣改编一部简·奥斯汀的小说。我想，有趣。
the extraordinary Hollywood producer
who actually started her work with Spinal Tap,
excuse me, literally one of my favorite films ever.
Sure, for sure.
So she wrote to me and said,
I've seen your sketch about the Victorian penis.
I wonder if you would fancy adapting a Jane Austen novel.
I thought, interesting.
有趣的转折。哇。我说，好吧，我试试。我试了一下。太棒了。那之后的其他剧本呢？原谅我的无知。那是你……
Interesting segue.
Wow.
I said, well, I'll give it a go.
I gave it a go.
Amazing.
Now what about other screen plays afterwards?
Forgive my ignorance.
Is that something that you...
不，一点也不。我写过……我们一直在原谅你的无知。写了很多没被拍出来的，其实。但我写过……我写过几个儿童电影，一个叫《魔法保姆麦克菲》，她是一个奇怪的、
No, not at all.
I've written...
We've been forgiving your ignorance.
Written loads that haven't been made, actually.
But I wrote...
I've written a couple of kids.
films, one called Nanny
Murphy, who's a strange,
长满疣的、巫婆一样的女人。而且其实，我们花了10年时间写了它的音乐剧，明年就要在西区上演了。不会吧。哇。谁写的音乐？加里·克拉克，他写了《唱街》的音乐，
sort of warty, witchy
woman.
And actually, we've
spent 10 years writing the musical of that
which is coming into the West End next year.
No way. Wow.
Who wrote the music for that?
Gary Clark, who wrote the music for
那是一部可爱的、美丽的爱尔兰电影。所以他是那种人，就是能写歌。他在纳什维尔待了很多年，你只要想想音乐产业，
Sing Street, which
was a lovely
sort of beautiful Irish film.
So he's
one of those people.
who just can write songs.
He spent years and years in Nashville,
and you just think about the music industry,
就充满了这些人……他曾经在一个乐队里，而且还不错，但他不喜欢名声，不喜欢聚光灯。所以他退隐了，开始写歌。他写过歌……我的意思是，和这么多伟大的艺术家合作过，他真是一位出色的词曲作者。我们写了大约十亿首歌，
is just amazingly full of these people who...
He was in a band, and it was kind of going,
but he didn't like the fame, he didn't like the glare.
So he retreated and started to write songs.
And he's written songs with...
I mean, so many of the greats,
he's just a wonderful songwriter.
And we have written about a billion songs,
剪掉了十亿首歌。我们写了太久了。我给了他几个基准。我说，想想汤姆·威茨的《剑鱼长号》。还有，你知道一个叫“老虎百合”的乐队吗？他们相当……他们中的几个。是的，是的。是的，就是那种东西。
cut a billion songs.
We've been writing it for so long.
I gave him a couple of touchstones.
I said, think Tom Waits, Swordfish Trombone.
And also, do you know a gang called the Tiger Lillies?
They're quite a couple of them.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that was the kind of thing.
我当时想要一种维多利亚时代的蒸汽朋克，稍微有点黑暗，你知道，有点马戏团的感觉，但不是，你知道，像黑暗的那种。听起来很棒。所以这就是我们一直在做的。那真的很酷。是的，我等不及了。如果我不提你的新项目《羊探长》，我就失职了。
I was like a Victorian steampunk slightly dark, you know,
a little bit on the circus side but not, you know, like dark.
That sounds great.
So that's what we've been doing.
That's really cool.
Yeah, I can't wait for that.
I would be remiss if we didn't mention your new project,
The Sheep Detective.
《羊探长》，那是关于什么的？克雷格·麦辛写的。伟大的克雷格·麦辛。哦，是的。是的，我爱克雷格。J.B.，你的老伙计。他写了《切尔诺贝利》。他真是个非常、非常棒的人。
The sheep detective, what is that about?
Craig Mason wrote that.
The great Craig Mason.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I love Craig.
J.B., your old buddy.
He wrote Chernobyl.
He's such a wonderful, wonderful man.
然后他改编了一本书，是的，关于一个牧羊人被谋杀了，他的羊破了案。我的意思是，就是这样。这就是梗概。你只会说，好的，我会参演。我会演一只羊。我会演任何东西。我会演一把扫帚。
And then he adapted a book where, yeah,
it's about a shepherd who gets murdered and his sheep solved the crime.
I mean, that's it.
That's the log line.
You just go, yes, I'll be in it.
I'll play a sheep.
I'll play anything.
I'll play a broom.
我会演任何东西。因为这个前提太好了。而且这是由休·杰克曼主演的。听起来是个很棒的故事。伙计们，抱歉，抱歉。不错。好。我注意到了。
I'll play anything.
Because it's such a good premise.
And this is starring Hugh Jack.
Sounds like a great yarn.
Guys, sorry, sorry.
Nice.
Good.
I noticed that.
不。谢谢。我听说这是一部非常、非常好的电影，父母也会喜欢的。因为它是为孩子们制作的，对吧？是你和……令人愉快的休·杰克曼。是这样吗？
No.
Thank you.
I hear this is a really, really good film
that parents would like as well.
Because it is made for the kids, right?
It's you and, and, uh,
the delightful Hugh Jackman.
Is that right?
我说对了吗？是的。你必须和……你必须和一些照片级真实的动物一起工作，还是？照片级真实的演员？不，我，不，我们，其实，我只参与了大约三周。我刚在芬兰拍完一部惊悚片。然后我要去拍电视剧，所以我算是插空和这群可爱的人待了三周。而且那，那真是太棒了。
Am I right about that?
Yeah.
Did you have to work with, you have to work with some photorealistic animals or some, or is it?
Photo-realistic actors?
No, I, no, we, actually, I was only on it for about three weeks.
I'd just done a thriller in Finland.
And then I was going on to the telly, so I sort of kind of dropped in for three weeks with these lovely bunch of folk.
and that, it was a gorgeous.
是的，听起来是个很棒的拍摄地点，对吧？你在哪里拍的？哦，天哪，现在你问我了。我的意思是，是在英国。是在英国，好的。而且其实，我们是在同一个村庄拍的第二部《魔法保姆麦克菲》，因为它是一个如画般的村庄。我不记得它叫什么了。
Yeah, it sounds like a gorgeous type of location, right?
Where did you shoot that?
Oh, God, now you're asking me.
I mean, it was in England.
It was in England, okay.
And actually, we shot the second Nana and Fee in the same village
because it's a kind of picture perfect village.
And I can't remember what it's called.
嗯，最重要的是。我想它叫汉布尔登，其实。我想我真的记住了，这简直是个该死的奇迹。是吗？鉴于我简直100岁了。这里有175度。是的。我的大脑在沸腾。
Well, most importantly.
I think it's called Hambledon, actually.
I think I've actually remembered that, which is a fucking miracle.
Was it?
Given that I'm literally 100.
175 degrees here.
Yeah.
My brain's boiling.
它离你家够近吗，你可以睡在自己的床上，还是你必须住在……不，所以不是。所以，所以不是。不。好的。那从来没发生过。
Was it close enough to your house
where you could sleep in your own bed
or did you have to stay in?
No, so not.
So, so not.
No.
Okay.
That never happens.
从来没有。你知道我喜欢英国的什么，住在英国的酒店，特别是一家小的英国酒店。是英式早餐。我崇拜英式早餐。谁不呢？那是什么？
Never.
You know what I love about England
singing at an English hotel,
especially a small English hotel.
It's an English breakfast.
I adore an English breakfast.
Who doesn't?
Which is what?
嗯，有不同种类的。所以，威尔，你吃什么？你喜欢小香肠吗？我不，是的，我避开黑布丁。但我喜欢鸡蛋和香肠。什么是黑布丁？我从来没吃过黑布丁。是的，黑布丁里有什么？你没吃过吗，肖恩？
Well, there's different kinds.
So, Will, what do you get?
You like the little sausages?
I don't, yeah, I shy away from the black puddings.
but I like eggs and sausage.
What's black pudding? I've never had black pudding.
Yeah, what's in a black pudding?
Haven't you, Sean?
糖蜜？是猪血。不。不，不是。是凝固的。确实是。它是猪血混合了各种香料和谷物。哦，天哪。就像哈吉斯。
Molasses?
It's pig's blood.
No.
No, it's not.
It's congeal.
It is. It's pig's blood mixed up with various sort of spices and grains.
Oh, my God.
It's like haggis.
因为我是苏格兰混血，哈吉斯是羊胃。哦，天哪。羊胃里塞满了各种内脏，切碎后混合了各种……刚才有人发出了羊叫声吗？哦，天哪。好吧，为什么我们那边有这种食物？是因为我们过去很穷吗？
Because I'm half Scottish and a haggis is a sheep's stomach.
Oh, my God.
The sheep's stomach is filled with all the sort of awful,
which is all chopped up with various bits of.
Did somebody just make a sheep noise?
Oh, my God.
Well, why do we have these kinds of foods over there?
Is it because we were poor?
这个国家太古老了，你必须想出如何用现有的东西做出能吃的东西，对吧？这是在……之前。而且你也不浪费任何东西。对。所以如果你杀了一头牛，你也吃了它该死的胃。还有它的舌头，整个。你唯一不吃的是它的毛。
The country's so old that you had to figure out
how to make stuff you could eat out of what was available, right?
This was before.
But also you didn't waste anything.
Right.
So if you killed a cow, you ate its fucking stomach as well.
And its tongue in the whole.
The only thing you didn't eat was its hair.
是的。你知道，还有它的角。你必须想出如何，如果你有一只动物，你杀了它，因为别忘了，这个国家……我想特别是苏格兰，很穷，非常穷。是的。直到最近，在很多地区，它仍然很穷。是的。
Yeah.
You know, and it's horns.
You had to work out how, if you had an animal and you killed it,
because you don't forget, it's really quite recent that the country's,
I suppose Scotland in particular was poor, very poor.
Yeah.
Until recently, and in many areas, it's still poor.
现在，你，我在英国待过的最长时间就是最近去年，大约三四个月。肖恩，你在那里做什么？艾玛，你，你是否像以前一样，仍然被这个国家的魅力和周围的一切以及历史所吸引？还是你只是觉得，它就是那样，是的，那是大本钟，那是那个东西。
Now, do you, the longest time, the longest I've ever spent in England
is just recently last year for like three or four months.
What were you doing with there, Sean?
Do you get, Emma, do you get, are you as entranial,
still by the charm of the country
and everything around it in the history?
Are you just kind of like, it is what it is
and yep, there's Big Ben, there's the thing.
我已经太习惯了，很难再欣赏它了，还是你仍然觉得，哇？哦不，我比年轻时更着迷了。我的意思是，我简直崇拜它。我是伦敦人，但我也是苏格兰人。我母亲是苏格兰人。所以对我来说，最美丽的乡村
I'm so used to it
that it's hard to appreciate it anymore, or do you still
feel like, wow?
Oh no, I'm much more in trans than I was when I was young.
I mean, I just adore it.
I'm a Londoner, but I'm also a Scot.
It's my mother Scottish.
So for me, the most beautiful countryside
是在苏格兰。而且苏格兰是狂野的，它是非常，你知道，它是不受约束的，它是无拘无束的，而且充满了最非凡的能量。而伦敦也是，你知道，一个非常珍贵的地方，因为每个人，这个巨大的城市里住着这群熙熙攘攘的人，总的来说相当和平。是的，我爱我的城市。我不太熟悉，
is in Scotland.
and Scotland is wild and it's very, you know, it's unheld, it's unbound,
and it's full of the most extraordinary energies.
And London is also, you know, a very precious place
because everyone, this great teeming bowl of people living in this massive city,
generally speaking quite peacefully.
Yeah, I love my city.
I'm not as familiar.
英国，其实，乡村。但英国的乡村可以相当令人叹为观止。是的，去北部的约克郡或诺森伯兰郡。或者，你知道，我们到处都在拍摄。我们去年在康沃尔拍摄，我从来没有真正花时间在康沃尔。我只想去那里住。它太精致了。而且实际上仍然充满了个性和社区感。
with England, actually, the countryside.
But the countryside in England can be quite breathtaking.
Yeah, to Yorkshire in the north or Northumberland.
Or, you know, we were shooting all over those.
We shot in Cornwall last year, and I'd never really spent any time in Cornwall.
And I just wanted to go and live there.
It was so exquisite.
And still full of character and community, actually.
你知道吗？我可以建议一个非剧本节目吗，艾玛，你去到处重新发现英国？这就对了。我们要制作它。听着，我们要向你推销。我们要联系你的人。你们都得跟我一起去。
You know what?
Might I suggest a non-scripted show, Emma,
where you go around and rediscover England?
There you go.
We're going to produce it.
Listen, we're going to pitch it to you.
We're going to get in touch with your people.
You all have to come with me.
是的。我是个忠实的亲英派。这些人知道。而且羊和你一起去，评论一下，羊一起去。然后在节目结束时，我们吃了它们？是的，当然。每一块。每一块。
Yes.
I'm a devoted anglophile.
These guys know.
And the sheep go with you and comment on a sheep come with.
And then at the end of the show, we eat them?
Yes, of course.
Every piece.
而且杰森拿走胃。杰森拿走胃。你们每个人都必须拿走一个特别令人不快的部位，比如胰腺，然后你们发明一个真正好的小食谱，专门针对那个部位。顺便说一句，我要把它说出来。我要把它说出来。现在有人在听，可能是在英国，他会说，这真是个好主意。
And Jason takes the stomach.
Jason takes the stomach.
You all have to take one particular really unpleasant part,
like the pancreas, and then you invent a really good little recipe just for that part.
By the coat, by the way, I'm going to put this out there.
I'm going to put this out there.
There is somebody listening right now, maybe over in the UK,
who's going to say, like, this is a great idea.
而且你会接到一个关于做的来电，对吧？我会非常想看艾玛游历英国。并发现不同地方的村庄。就像斯坦利·图齐在意大利那样。我等不及了。我等不及了。我已经是个执行制片人了。我会到处不停地说，
And you are going to get an incoming call about doing, right?
I would watch the hell out of Emma going through England.
and discovering villages in different places.
Like Stanley Tucci and Italy.
I can't wait.
I'm an EP on it already.
I'll just go around saying endlessly,
你想要点增益吗。那是我的最爱短语。你想要点增益。你想要更多我吗？那是杰森。当他说，你想要点增益。听起来太……哦，是的，我想我确实想要点增益。
you want some gain.
That was my favorite phrase.
You want some gain.
You want more of me?
That was Jason.
As he was said, you want some gain.
It just sounded so.
Ooh, yes, I think I do want some gain.
那是热门播客。你接下来要建议什么？艾玛，我们占用了你太多时间了。这已经，可能已经一个小时了。有你在这里真是太高兴了。这真的很快。希望你能凉快下来，跳进游泳池。这很快。
That's hot podcast.
What are you going to suggest next?
Emma, we have taken up too much of your time.
It's been, it's probably been an hour.
What an absolute delight to have you here.
That was real fast.
I hope you get to cool off and jump in a pool.
It was fast.
我们可以永远聊下去。不，我真的要走了。我在花园里放了那个该死的喷雾器。我现在要去站在里面。我觉得我们甚至没问到任何问题。下次你来节目时，我们真的会问你一些问题。下次，马利斯。
We could have gone on forever.
No, I'm literally going to go.
I put the blooming scocher thing on in the garden.
I'm going to go and stand in it now.
I don't think we got to any questions even.
On the next time you come on the show,
we're actually going to ask you some questions.
On the next, Marlis.
是的。那太可爱了，伙计们。非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢你们花这么多时间，以及你们所做的一切。我们只是粉丝，就像……是的，我们是。
Yeah.
That was so lovely, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you for doing so much for your time
and for everything that you do.
and we're just such fans as just...
Yeah, we are.
好吧，同样回敬你们，你们每一个人，我深深地爱着你们。同样。谢谢，亲爱的。确保你把你的孩子们从地板上捡起来，捡……是的，绝对。不，他们走了。他们早就走了。他们脸朝下躺在湿草坪上。
Well, right back at you, every single one of you, I love you deeply.
Likewise.
Thank you, my dear.
Make sure you pick your kids up off the floor and pick...
Yeah, absolutely.
No, they've gone.
They've long gone.
They're lying face down on the wet lawn.
好的，安妮。再见。谢谢，阿尔玛。再见。伙计们，艾玛·汤普森。你看过《长日留痕》吗？是的。是的。
All right, Annie.
Fairly well.
Thanks, Alma.
Bye.
Guys, Emma Thompson.
Have you seen Remains of the Day?
Yes.
我的意思是，我看过很多次了。你觉得她拍了多少部电影？我敢打赌她拍了65部电影。嗯，有什么比那更好的吗？她拍了多少部伟大的电影？我知道。就像很多。64。
I mean, I've seen that so many times.
How many films do you think she's done?
I bet she's done 65 movies.
Well, what's better than that?
How many great films has she done?
I know.
Like so many.
64.
这么多令人难以置信的表演。是的。而且在每个类型里都如此不同。毫不费力。是的。我是认真的。她，总是，她的每个角色里总有一种调皮的小眨眼。哦，你觉得她有点调皮，是吗？
So many incredible performances.
Yeah.
And just so different in every genre.
Effortless.
Yeah.
And I meant it.
She is, there's always, there's some sort of cheeky little wink always to each one of her characters.
Oh, you find her to be a little cheeky, do you?
有点调皮。她有点调皮。不，她也，她也散发出一种……她会照顾我的感觉。就像，她是我的妈妈。是的。你知道，我喜欢那样。我想要她照顾我。我要把我的号码发给她。
It's a bit cheeky.
She's a bit cheeky.
No, she also, she also emanates kind of like she's going to take care of me.
Like, she's my mom.
Yes.
You know, and I like that.
I want her to take care of me.
I'm going to send her my number.
我的意思是，想想看，《真爱至上》，忘了那个每个人都还在谈论的巨大热门。这简直，哦，天哪。我觉得你浪费了一个机会，威尔。你真的可以走上一条关于角色和电影的不可思议的记忆之路。结果你在谈论哈吉斯和该死的……因为我们只是在聊天，伙计。我们只是在串门，不是吗？
I mean, thinking about it, Love Actually,
forgot about that massive hit that everybody's still.
It's just, oh, God.
I think you squandered an opportunity there, Will.
You really could have gone down an incredible memory lane of parts and movies and stuff.
And said, you're fucking talking about haggis and God damn.
Because we're just having a conversation, man.
We're just visiting, weren't we?
是的，我们只是在进行一次快速的小访问，不是吗？我们不是记者。不。是的，我们得让她再来。是的，你知道，我们只是……真爱至上。我们只是简单的家伙，你知道，我们不太聪明。事实上，我们是“Smartless”。
Yeah, we're just having a quick little visit, weren't we?
We're not journalists.
No.
Yeah, we'll have to have her back.
Yeah, you know, we're just...
Love action.
We're just simple guys, you know, we're not very smart.
In fact, we're smart less.
哦。哦，哇。所以，看，所以就在那里，我只是在引入一个新的结束语，而不是“再见”。好的。我们想出某种方式来只说，是的，我想我们只是有点“Smartless”。然后就结束了。但那是你唯一能用的。你只能说“我们是Smartless”。
Oh.
Oh, wow.
So, see, so right there, I was just introducing a new sign-off instead of buy.
Okay.
We work on some sort of way to just say, yeah, I guess we're just kind of smart less.
And then it's over.
But that's the only one you can use then.
You can only say we're a spotless.
对，但你得想办法把它放进句子里。是的，但这可能就像……但这来自于我们这样做的过程。你知道我的意思吗？就像那是一个自然的进展。在某种程度上，它几乎是……你称之为“副产品”。节目的副产品。
Right, but you've got to somehow work that into the sentence.
Yeah, but that could just be like...
But that came out of this process of us doing that.
Do you know what I mean?
Like that's a natural progression.
In a way, it's almost...
You call it like a buy product.
A buy product of the show.
再见。Smartless是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科100%有机和手工制作的。
Bye.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly.
handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barbico.
再见。Smartless是由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjarv和Bennett Barbico百分之百有机且手工制作的。